Chloe Bennet vacations with her Valley  Girl co-star Logan Paul so dreamy the 25  year old agents of shield star and the  22 year old Internet personality were  spotted getting cozy in Hawaii over the  holiday weekend the pair was seen  swimming embracing and kissing while  taking a dip in the ocean together  Chloe shared this sweet snap celebrating  the fourth of July with her possible new  man while boating with their pals Logan  and Chloe have been spending plenty of  time together shooting the new musical  remake of valley girl that's been  scheduled to be out next year and have  been documenting the fun on social media  the seemingly budding romance comes  after Chloe reportedly split from  longtime boyfriend actor Austin Nichols  after almost four years together take on  the space you need but right now I need  my own the last shot Chloe shared of  Austin on social media was on  Valentine's Day earlier this year  [Music]